à
[Musique]
la une de ce banc parisien revient sur
le déplacement de jean luc mélenchon ce
week end à lille je vous demande
d'accueillir jean luc mélenchon alors
que se plaisait la traditionnelle
braderie de lille jean luc mélenchon a
prononcé un discours il a notamment été
question d'écologie de sobriété
énergétique sauf qu'à son départ l'homme
politique est monté à bord d'un 4 4 un
bad buzz pour jean luc mélenchon qui a
vivement fait réagir sur les réseaux
sociaux après avoir rappelé aux gens
l'importance de l'écologie dans son
discours de lille jean luc mélenchon
repas dans son 4 4 fais comme je dis
mais ne fais pas comme je roule mais sur
twitter certains de ses soutiens ont
tenté de le sortir de ce bad buzz jean
luc mélenchon n'a pas de voiture c'est
une location par ailleurs c'est une
hybride elle a transporté 5 personnes et
le matériel moins polluant qu'un
prestataire avec camion alors jean-luc
mélenchon a perçu en 4 4 dans les rues
de lille comprenez vous que cela fasse
scandale
[Musique]
ça me fait mal pour mon jean lui même
rythme parce que guy madore il veut tout
faire comme moi qui ont 4 404 voix là
bas c'est ça qu'est ce qui se passe non
ah non selon son entourage et selon les
infos c'est un véhicule hybride hybride
gilou et 70 euros par jour ils ont pris
ça parce qu'ils peuvent être nombreux
dedans il ya un grand coffre ils peuvent
mettre tout le matériel ça et vite et
prendre un camion de location donc pour
moi y'a pas d'autres n'y a pas de
polémique il a le droit de prendre ce
type de véhicule c'est pas
contradictoire avec son doigt pas la
pole je la vois pas la polémique
là-dessus motion non j'ai pas de pierre
serre compte par contre toi de toi je ne
te vois pas devenu hymne à la poste je
peux dire quelque chose non il adore
jeep encore une fois des symboles jeudi
l'autre jour le jeep malgré tout ça
reste à 4,410 merçi pour malgré tout pas
et le problème c'est que ce monsieur si
donnez pas de leçons il fait ce qu'il
veut de ce week-end mais donne des
leçons sur la démocratie est dit la
république c'est moi et donne des
censures l'écologie il arrive en 4
parties déjà séjourné à donner des
leçons et puis finalement elle arrive
avec la voiture qui est par définition
de gypse tu la mairie m c'est une
hybride fugees c'est un 4-4-2 insultant
estime hybride avec une part de
mélenchon michel font mais je défends le
4-4 et maison il savait qu'il serait
particulièrement bienvenue dans tous les
sens mais tout ce qui se passe autour de
jean luc mélenchon est un fait politique
en outre ce sens il savait que ses
opposants il repart fouillé regarder et
là ils ont relevé trois choses non
seulement ils ont il a pris un gros 4 4
mais en plus c'est une marque américaine
dont le point qu'américaines exactement
ça c'est vrai et par ailleurs il ya une
cocarde tricolore alors une cocarde
tricolore il ne peut pas avoir de
cocardes tricolores il met des
parlementaires
gouvernement
était prêt si la digue il faut mettre un
slip bleu blanc rouge et leur courage a
dit oui parce qu'il y avait quatre mince
dans la voiture et c'est un parlement a
oui ça donc au début certaines
options matin sur l'a4 dans la voiture
[Applaudissements]
je vais pas arrêter les gars chaque
passe partout
mais voilà effectivement c'est un fait
politique donc les opposants vont aller
se jeter dessus voilà c'est pour ça
alors s'explique me suis rappelé que
cette polémique elle a été lancée et
relayé par eric naulleau qui détestent
jean luc mélenchon donc déjà ils sont
pas très objectif sur l'histoire de la
région de française ils ont bien
expliqué que des turcs voiture de
location qu'ils ont cherché des voitures
françaises qui n'en avaient plus à
cacher aux français les voitures
toitures par sa dans le 91 ap stop ces
français ces français vous prenez pas la
tête pour la voiture c'est français ses
jeeps cfia c'est le groupe c'est l'anti
ses peugeot citroën est pas foncer
excuse moi ça va la voiture est français
c'est le groupe c'est l'anti c'est speed
il a créé
la voiture française hybride mais
hybride ça veut dire que quand elle est
en partie essence alain consomme
énormément donc je reviens sur ce que
dit mathieu faites ce que je dis ne
faites pas ce que je fais machin il veut
tout faire mais tout le monde mais en
vérité quant à ivry de foyers bride
silva sur l'autoroute il va énormément
consommer ça reste un 4 4 voilà en
attendant contrairement à certains
politiques il prend pas un jet privé
pour faire déplacer au il va en voiture
comme le concède mais non il peut pas
aller jusque là
j'ai d'énormes conneries
culture les fremm tourin meglio
président la plata phrase elle tient pas
debout tu prends un jet privé ses
rideaux merci envoie c'est tout mais
justement
on savait qu'ils ne prendraient la
pression nous révéler un dossier de file
s'en cache même pas il est devant tout
le monde qui a aucun problème à ce que
je pense qu'il n'a pas dû la police
belge
moi si vous montez dans mon cas
je te dis oui il en politique ne voit
jamais les coups venir comme sarko driss
elle n'avait pas vu le coup du fouquet's
arrivé que c'est à ils sont tellement
dans une tour d'ivoire où tout le monde
est plein fouet mais les utilisateurs
qui veut se faire élever et quel rôle
alors les pauvres et qui en fait tu veux
tous les attributs bien sûr cette
voiture
chez dodo c'est alors à prendre sa
voiture du garage parce que hier à ww1
pas une voiture de location
wwf ou mais pourquoi ils roulent pas en
électrique puisqu'il casse les couilles
à tout le monde pour qu'on roule en
annonçant que ça c'est le mobile d euros
qu'elle lui est là car où les en
électrique pourquoi tous ces politiques
disent aux gens roulaient arrêté de
rouler avec vos nerfs à une cas 10 ans
parce que vous êtes critères 3 on va
vous mettre 68 euros damende c'est parce
que vous polluez eux mais non c'est la
vérité c'est la vérité on dit aux gens
de changer de voiture il ya des gens là
des gens dans rouen des gens dans les
grandes villes ils peuvent plus aller
travailler parce qu'ils ont une voiture
qu'à plus de dix ans tu ne peux plus
aller travailler parce que ta voiture la
plus de dix ans certains voiture c'est
2011 tu peux pas être à railler ses on
est chez les fous rires oui et pourquoi
moi c'est moi vous m'avez défendu et
jean luc mélenchon
[Applaudissements]
ference et vous ne faites pas un
discours écolo en nous disant c'est pas
comme si fait comme ça et pas de
barbecue et pas de trucs et je m'en
excuse des lâches et sur le plateau
voilà oui gaylib adobuzz vous n'avez pas
donné votre vie à la politique en
tentant sans doute ce genre de personne
il oui moi je donne ma vie à la
politique je fais tout avec la politique
et ben si tu donnes ta vie à la
politique tout habitue la base sur ce
que tu dis donc à ce moment là bas tu
travailles pas en 4k tu fais des trucs
écolos tu fais ce qui est en rapport
avec ton dit tout discours en fait donc
je trouve ça vraiment en verve pour moi
c'est en gros je vous chie à la gueule
mais ce que je voulais faire des trucs
mais en fait je suis en berne parce que
ben je vous emmerde moi je le prends
comme ça parce que nous les personnes
lambda on n'y connaît rien en voiture
moi je vous ai regardé dans la pub je
vous ai dit ben en fait c'est quoi comme
battus raconte moi j'y connais rien sur
tout ce que je vois c'est le symbole
comme ce que disent et mathieu est le
symbole c'est qu'ils se baladent en 4 4
et qui nous emmerdent américains 0ea
géraldine là mais moi je suis évidemment
d'accord avec mes petits camarades m'ont
revanche jeu mais non parce que je
trouve que vous êtes bien naïf on
s'assure depuis quand mélenchon il est
écolo milan n'a rien à [ __ ] de
l'écologie ont fait près de 6 des dehors
mais paraît-il heureux s'il vous plaît
mon tennis dont qui saignait les
récollets si ça arrive à sandrine
rousseau la ouais on peut dire oui quand
même là quand même elle exagère parce
qu'elle me d'antin la journée les
trottinettes et des vélos à rallonge
mais sandrine ans et les autres comme et
lanchon c'est juste une sorte d'
alliances de circonstance et cynique
juste opportunit il a trouvé l'écologie
prévenu pts et sinon à la fosse qui
l'intéressent et je veux voir ses sous
sols par exactions seydoux non mais là
on est dans une formule anti mélenchon
parle
d'un avocat mais là vous mélangez tout
ça dans une tribune anti mélange est
d'accord avec lui
dimanche il a maintenant on est breton
moto
areva turbo il avait tout va bien il
prend une voiture hybride justement pour
pas trop polis fait attention il prend
pas un camion quartiers et villes
allemandes une belle voiture ils le
disent en gros 4 4
il ya tout le matériel dont contre la
camion comme mon nom c'est pour
économiser richesse est absurde on est
est ce que tu vas bataille s'est
réveillée demander si le perchiste
poèmes etc à sa caméra dans le camp de
ceux qui croient qu'il s'en fout il
pense à une chose et une seule mélenchon
à lui tu le connais toi d'où tu connais
d'où tu le connais alors moi je vais
vous dire mais je tenais je n'ai
rencontré
[Applaudissements]
la route et des bêtises je vous dis je
viens d'en d'une tribu d'un pays
mélenchon
qui d'autre munichois allaient rester
fidèle à son style son travail dans la
rue
sinon ton âge maintenant les gens
dégagent connard etc il parle d'écologie
sera il fait tout le contraire à la
république c'est moi c'est d'une
prétention à chaque fois il a des torts
mais là vous la seringue et c'est
quelqu'un qui est oui et rigide sujet
will et parfois pas sympathique parfois
il des tombes des gens mais là où le
flinguer poursuit au tibet n'est pas ce
qu'il prévoyait à lui seul la lizadeel
mamie daniel à non mais moi j'aurais
trouvé qui laisse à celle des gueules
qui partent en trottinette ouais ça
c'est sympa ça c'est ça ce revient cette
année
à vélo trottinette aussi recevoir les
maires n'avaient blague à part on dénie
à la raison comme extra partie en
trottinette vous ça fait autant
et vous savez pas s'y rendre sur paris
bah ouais sur paris andré l'entretien
photothèque mélenchon
ce sont les spectateurs s'il vous plaît
pour cent oui comprennent la polémique
gouaille 60% carrier non à à 40 buts en
voilà temps kwaljima et babagana quand
un tueur s'est senti mal